السايبر مرض العصر الحديث من اكثر انواع
الخرف الشيوعا وهو يحدث بسبب موت الخايه
العصبيه في المخ ولا سيما مع التقدم في
العمر وقد يصيب البعض في سن مبكرا لكن لا
يعرف الخبراء تحديدا السبب وراء ذلك
[موسيقى]
البحوث اظهرت ان مرض السايمر لا يمكن
الشفاء منه ولكن يمكن تخفيف اعراضه بهدف
الحفاظ على القدرات المعرفيه ومهارات
التواصل الاجتماعي قدر الامكان
والجديد هنا ان شركه الادويه اليابانيه
كشفت انها شعرت عقارها الذي تمت المصادقه
عليه مؤ
خرا الى مرض
26 و 500 الف دولار في السنه بينما توقع
محللون من وستريت ان يبلغ سعر العقار له
20,000 دولار سنويا
[موسيقى]
والعقاقير الامريكيه تقدم مهما في معالجه
مرض
يعملوا علاج جديد على ابطاء التدهور
المعرفي للمرضى وتحديدا اولئك الذين لم
يصلوا بعد الى مراحل متقدمه من المراه
[موسيقى]